thank you
[Music]
uh this next one's semi-related to that
so um have you guys have you guys
um noticed that when people hang up
American flags there's almost like a
weird
um huge Vibe huge Vibe yeah like a
racist like you you so people say it's
so weird that America stands for the
nation the nation has a lot of different
parties but these days it feels like if
you're rocking an American flag you're
like a right-wing extremist or some [__]
really yeah wow I wonder if you're
rocking this in your lawn I think that's
kind of cute that's hilarious that's
Fourth of July that's very festive did
that here that would just get so
obliterated really really like in
California I see so little Flags you
know what you know what so so [__]
little now so my my mother-in-law she
lives in San Gabriel and every year for
Fourth of July the city of San Diego but
they just put little uh you uh USA flags
yeah and everyone's lawn used to be a
line they still do it though they still
do it every year and it's I go yeah it's
[__] the Fourth of July baby yep I
like it is that a Texas flag on the side
there should be a bear video did you
yeah how is this why is it a bear
not anymore though it is weird but
that's just here right like I feel like
there's some states where they still
live like that yeah I go to Texas
there's American flags over Utah Flags
everywhere I think I see more Mexican
flags here than American flags in La I'm
glad you mentioned that because this
particular incident happened in Oklahoma
or the sound on now and you can
there's a lady at a ring doorbell is she
gonna bring over pie she's going to the
house that has those decorations oh no
just go home oh no she's gonna tell them
that they get down huh oh she's peeing
on it wait
or what is this
what did you say wow oh I thought she
was taking a piss my bad
American yeah was she a white lady she's
a white lady that's that's really rude
why are like white ladies like the
[__] top of the woke chain right now
like they hate America the most and like
what's going on you know what I say to
her single white lady
at least five she wasn't actually peeing
on the flight yeah was she hey you know
what I'm saying bro the more I travel to
different countries the more I'm like
very proud to be in America America's a
[__] [__] I'm like we got it so
[__] good over here bro we should not
be complaining about as much as we can
it's because we're fighting over there
so we don't have to find them over here
you know what I'm saying come on bro
yeah brother come on brother that's the
funniest thing is like the ability to
complain is a sign of living in a
[__] good condition oh yeah dude like
some places are so [__] worse off and
they're not allowed to open their mouth
about that yeah you're just struggling
to survive not thinking about any other
problems yeah my mom loves America but
she's like I gotta live in Japan because
I can't speak English that well and I'm
afraid of driving but if it was shaped
like Japan I'd be there she was like if
the city was like you had trains and all
that yeah so at one point this woman
um she says she's coming she's she was
daring this person to shoot her because
they think they're such a trump
supporter dude this is That's So Rude
what the [__] is wrong with people this
homeowner says I don't know why why
would I shoot you yeah and then she said
she's coming back to blow your house up
that's what she said yeah I'm coming
back to blow your house she said she's
just crazy you're gonna blow my house up
she's like yes I'm coming back so you
better be ready and then um so the
police report was filed they're looking
for the woman nobody knows who she is
she doesn't even live there maybe she
meant it in the same way that that one
dude did on the plane where he blew up
the bathroom and everyone thought it was
a bomb [__]
she wasn't peeing right I don't think
she was me she was just doing a little
squat why would she just squat but it is
crazy recent Rebrand of the flag yeah
like it's not the same feeling like you
know like even that it's like
threatening it's the most recent one
that um
the women's uh World Cup when they
played The Anthem like only half of them
was saluting the other half was like not
nah this ain't even play Fruit wait the
American team the American team they
play for [__] America yeah but they
half of them like nah this is I don't
even I only play the sport I don't even
stand for this it's like then don't go
have you guys seen the picture of of
Jesse Owens he was a um an Olympian
right yeah an African-American Olympian
pretty famous yeah very famous he
actually
um went to the Olympics and won in
Germany in Nazi Germany and you can see
him up on the podium like [__]
yeah like all this yeah in 1935 that's
pretty cool
crazy you know in his in his um in his
like what do you call it like his uh uh
interview or whatever he was like Nazi
Germany treated them better than America
do you say that [__]
he's like I gotta say and this might be
a hot tape I kind of love
they're kind of cool guys well
especially back then because like you
know our president would meet with them
and [__] we didn't know yeah we say we
don't know but we don't you know who
knows yeah but it is crazy in a sense of
it right now
dude how about a barbecue now how about
a [__] Barbie July 4th barbecue I
think you seem like a trump supporter
really yeah you're grilling hot dogs and
not carne asada
unless you're growing veggies oh my
whole life right now is probably the
least patriotic time that I felt
you know yeah whereas like like low
military recruitment no one wants to
join military like just like public
service members want people to become
cops or firefighters apparently that's
not just America though it's just all
over the world like people are not
joining like I think China has an issue
with uh military recruitment Russia's
having one you know with the war and
stuff and I think um
there's like this like feeling of people
giving up with institution but people
have always been pro-america like
Americans have been the most patriotic
so much so that other countries go I can
say [__] China because I want to be
American you know like all of our
parents but isn't there a disconnect
because like dude I don't know if you
guys see these videos but like on July
4th for example I saw a plane that was
flying in like to LAX or whatever and
like the entire sky like might as well
have been daylight like it was like lit
up every [__] way like I feel like
the fireworks it's like the people still
have that Vibe but the institutions are
like preaching against it like they call
it nationalism if you're if you have a
flag outside you're a nationalist and
you're a white supremacist and that's
fireworks are more like party time
that's Party Time versus like I'm
American today yeah that's it's more
just like tradition of Fourth of July
yeah right I feel like immigrants are
more American than Americans
yeah absolutely because like when my
parents got their citizenship you know
they give you those little cheap little
plastic Flags they couldn't throw that
[__] away yeah they kept that it's a
piece of [__] two cent like they give
you a plat like they look it's [__] it
says made in China you know what I mean
it's a patriotic ass black so they
earned it yeah and then they kept that
[__] like it was [__] given by god
dude dude if my father-in-law flies the
flag right and um because his dad like
they came here from the Philippines and
like they you know everyone went in the
Navy and so like military is big and
America's big so he'll fly the flag and
if there's like a rainstorm he like you
see him like get his [__] coat on and
go outside to get the flag out of the
rain yeah it's like it's real over there
yeah my opinion still lays on if you
can't do a good thing for your own
Community within arm's length you don't
get to [__] tell the world how to
feel like you just can't talk like that
that's a good place to start there's
some Mexican immigrants that come here
and they do so much for their [__]
Community it's insane and then there's
some like people that have lived here
for like three generations that stay at
home they don't know anybody no one
likes them they don't like anyone and
they want you to not like anybody and
it's like why why are we listening to
them that's very true dude the idea
though that this [__] this leaves
drive my she sees this and it burns it
up she's like oh I see so you're a
Trumper
like this occupied her whole day it
burns her up he looks like a wizard he
has like one inflatable for every event
like for Christmas and whatever a Easter
Bunny and there's that crazy [__]
coming over every day for whatever
festivity that's a wild way decision
issue angry at [__] Uncle Sam riding
a rocket I don't know I get 30 more of
these yeah
she's acting like that's the swastika
yeah yeah it's like people that that
hate capitalism yet they're like such a
vital part of it yeah you're a piece of
it too dude they hate capitalism they
they wear a shirt they got on Amazon
that says it's a capitalism I think
there's one girl she's on she's always
on like social media talking about
capitalism is bad and I'm like wall out
her iPhone bro she's like taking videos
of her in her Tesla I'm like what are
you talking about capitalism is bad
you're in a test you see the MSNBC tweet
where they're like
um what's the right wing uh fixation on
Fitness yes like everything's branded so
[__] I know is it because now being
like working out is unhealthy is a
left-wing thing yeah yeah yeah Being Fit
is a right wing yeah
and it has white supremacist Origins
yeah Fitness has white supremacist
Origins I've seen that swear [__] Vox
dude people are nuts people are so
[__] Goods we're so [__] it's over
it's over you guys it's it dude tracking
the weather has white supremacists
yeah
pretty white supremacist isn't it it's
it's sad to admit that it is the product
of Peace like and it's sad that that's a
byproduct that will always happen when
nothing when we have nothing to do and
there's not a lot of Hardcore [__]
people find [__] reasons man you
gotta do more stuff I think I actually
think this will like generation of
wokeness right it's because people have
been
um hypnotized So Long by government
propaganda and they're for the first
time angry about oh wait all these
things that I was told was a lie where
most of us grew up thinking duh
government propaganda exists we're not
Saints like we're an Empire I ate it up
you ate it up so did you have animosity
towards the US when it first when you
first woke up to it yes extremely so
right but towards the institutions not
the US right yeah but I hear the U.S I
think about my parents it's in my and
like Nikki's parents and like right but
it's Mr what I'm trying to point out
it's misdirected anger yeah it's like
people were seeing mass at a mass level
of people waking up to the lives yes and
then they're going well that flag equals
lies oh that's true
and imperialism and whatever and I don't
want any part of that it does break my
heart that yeah like I don't equate the
flag to that no I mean but I feel like
when other countries when they see the
flag they're terrified because of what
it's done to maybe their family yeah
it's misdirected anger because I equate
the CIA me too to what's happened or you
know small organizations with it that
infiltrated and took over or like but
that was when they were corrupt now
they're not
yeah they're all good for example right
for example that's kind of what we're
dealing with right now unfortunately but
but I think the problem is people can't
think in terms of nuance so all they see
is good or bad well also people can't
think in terms of like outside of their
Community or their friend Circle right
they're heavily influenced by that
before it even gets into like any
government propaganda you also need to
be to have a clear story and what they
do so well in these institutions is they
muck the story up so much it's
impossible to tell quickly and you only
got three minutes every [__] news hit
and so how are you gonna ever tell and
how many people are actually going to do
some deep searching never happening no
and actually put in the time to do that
I just read the headlines and I spout
out to everyone I mean yeah
that that's uh Fair